rachel campos duffy is the co-host of
fox and friends weekend she joins us
tonight rachel campbell stuffy thank you
so much for coming on this seems like
the kind of issue
since the government contr effectively
controls the baby formula market most
people don't even know that that they
would jump on you don't want to be the
president who's presiding over a country
with none of baby formula why are they
ignoring this
you know it's so interesting because
this past week you started the week by
doing a monologue talking about the fact
that the left is waging a war on god and
i would say they're also waging a war on
families and if you look at what they've
done everything from you know crt
inflation abortion
you know gender ideology in your child's
school even the crime rate all of this
is making it harder for you to have and
raise a family and so this baby formula
situation you know it may not be
intentional maybe it's just incompetence
on their part but it just shows you
that they just don't care it's not a
priority for them i mean look they knew
you laid it out perfectly they the fda
told this company this abbott firm that
makes formula that they had to shut down
which is good if there was potential
contamination we want that but they knew
that they produced 40 percent of our
nation's formula which by the way again
not a very healthy arrangement there but
they knew that and so they better have a
plan if they're going to shut down the
plant to either you know get it up and
going quickly or source formula from
some other place but they didn't do that
it just shows that they're just they
just don't care about you they just
don't care about families they don't
care about moms they told you this past
week what they do care about they said
the number one thing and by the way this
was both parties the number one thing
was the war in ukraine and look how
quickly within a week they got 40
billion dollars over to ukraine 40
billion dollars but they can't figure
out how to get formula to moms and i
tell you what um tell a mom who can't
feed a baby in the middle of the night
uh that ukraine is their number one
problem uh
yeah they're gonna be angry and moms
across america are angry and tucker
they're not hoarding they're doing
networks across the internet trying to
breastfeed and provide um banks of milk
for other moms they're trying to help
each other it's far from this ugly image
that they're um you know that they're
portraying of mothers and one last thing
too you know you can maybe forgive uh
joe biden who probably hasn't dealt with
baby formula in 60 years um for not
understanding how serious and
life-saving this crisis um is it's it's
life or death for many people i by the
way had a baby who had to have
my breast milk fortified in order to
survive until her her life-saving heart
surgery because she had downs and
couldn't nurse um so this is serious
business but what about
buddha judge i mean this is also a
supply chain issue um he's at the center
of this and you know he loves to tell us
that he has those twins but he's much
more interested in making a point about
lgbtq plus families than he is about
locking arms with moms right now and
figuring out how to solve this problem
yeah i mean maybe because families are
the last bulwark the first and last
bulwark against tyranny if you have a
strong family you can't be pushed around
so maybe that's why they're not so
interested in
helping us have strong families do you
think that's possible that's absolutely
right
that's absolutely right but also again
it's about tucker it's also about their
priorities i mean you you talked about
the
formula that was going to the border so
why is that happening that's happening
because they don't want to have bad
press of
women coming over the border who maybe
need formula because they're probably
not nursing in the desert as they make
that dangerous journey and they don't
want bad press because they don't want
their policies to end this policy is
important to them that and and they have
done everything they could to keep it
opaque um and so we don't know what's
going on that's why they do those
flights in the middle of the night um
that's why they didn't want the fox
drone over the del rio del rio bridge i
guarantee you right now tucker
that they are spending much more time
and resources trying to locate that
border patrol agent the whistleblower
who took that picture and gave it to
representative camach i bet they're more
interested in that than they are in the
14 terrorists who cross the desert that
we know of
right now so that's what they care about
that is such a good point rachel
campbell stephanie great to see you
thank you so much
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight